great I'm so excited to be here thank
you everybody so Nick talked a little
bit about me i do want to point out that
the links to all of the demos that I'm
going to use and some extra rating if
you're interested is always down there
at the bottom of the screen it's going
to be at KDK to github I yo /
localization so you can go ahead and
take a look at the list of links anytime
if you want to um so this happens to me
in the US kind of a lot I finish a build
like this in the CSS I've perfectly
established a lovely vertical grid that
the designer wanted all the images align
all the headlines align all of the
call-to-action buttons align it's great
it's perfect time for a donut and then I
switch into German
and it's terrible the long headlines
broke the grid that we had the buttons
the buttons are terrible that's we can't
have that it is not time for a donut
this happens kind of a lot even worse
still in English when we let the content
owners go into the content management
system and they start changing the text
they move my buttons around again
honestly stop hit so probably this build
was not so perfect after all and we're
going to have to take care of it ah
Getty Images we localize our site into
over 20 different language and
localization versions so I've kind of
learned quite a lot in the past couple
years about how to build a site so that
it's going to work with a ton of
different text around it let me stop for
a minute just to talk about what exactly
is localization when pics are released
their Japanese dubbed version of inside
out they changed the green peppers from
the original broccoli from the original
version into green peppers because in
Japan green peppers are the universally
reviled vegetable for children
localization can include emotional and
cultural changes like this as well as
just switching the language over
localization can also include all of the
different changes that you have to have
four units of measurement and even the
way that very large numbers are
formatted and today what I'm going to be
talking about is not the entire
localization stack that's a bigger
problem than I can solve in 30 minutes
but I'm going to talk about how to
handle all of those changes using CSS
the results of all of those changes and
and this isn't just for translated
content even if you're a small site who
doesn't have to worry about going into
multiple languages you probably have
content owners and a content management
system or perhaps you have
user-generated content or content coming
from a database and at the very least I
would urge you to consider respecting
the device font sizes when a user with
less than
our vision changes their font size to be
a little bit bigger so that your boxes
don't break when that happens okay cool
so let's first talk about images and
embedded text embedded in images don't
worry this is not going to be the last
kitten that I'm going to show you today
I know you're concerned what we want is
we want for the image to be the exact
same on every version of our site but we
want the text to change okay well that's
not too hard but um I don't really want
to host 20 different images with 20
different languages embedded in the text
do I worse whenever the text changes I
don't want to make 20 new images in
Photoshop yuck so instead we're going to
use our modern CSS skills to let the
text be text and the image be an image
why do we care so much about letting the
text be text maybe we want a foreign
trained traveler to be able to buy a
train ticket that would be great maybe
for SEO that's kind of important i guess
uh uh yeah so text should just stay text
that would be better languages are often
much different sizes here we have German
it's three lines long German in Spanish
are usually much longer than English
Japanese and Hebrew for example I'm
often much shorter than English so we
have to worry about making sure that our
box is going to be different sizes in
both directions okay cool let's start
with the markup and then some pretty
simple styles throughout i'm not going
to show you the reset so i assume you
all already know all about that in case
you haven't seen it before the figure is
a new element with html5 and it is
perfect for containing both an image
just an image tag and a caption which is
the text its associated with the image
such lovely because we can semantically
associate our image and its text
together double thumbs up yeah and then
we have some not too exciting styling
where we set some sizes and the color on
our caption image
the first thing we're going to do is
we're going to want to position the
bottom of the fig caption element to the
bottom of the figure element okay we can
do that using position absolute right
bottom zero at close what's going to
position it to the bottom of the
containing of the the viewport the
browser window because it's positioned
absolutely for everything instead what
we also need to do is to capture the fig
captions position in context by adding
position relative on the parent figure
element itself thus we now have the
caption at the bottom of the figure
element it's been captured so cool cool
next let's take care of those let's take
care of those pink stripes on the side
that's pretty ugly the cool thing we can
do with this is we can use the CSS
intrinsic width module now this is
relatively new so do check the browser
support that you use earlier yoona
mentioned can i use calm and that's a
great way to see what supported you can
also use the Mozilla developer network
to get a good idea of whether the thing
that you need to use is supported for
your browser do we use a fallback in
this case i've used macs with 400 pixels
and then that's overrated overwritten by
browsers that support it with Max with
Max content and what I've said it to be
is max content Nick told the choke using
yeah max content earlier what this means
is it's going to make the parent
elements maximum with only as wide as it
needs to be to contain all of its
children so this is what gives us this
we don't have those pink stripes anymore
it's just contained by its content which
is pretty sweet the last thing that we
need to do is set a max height and a max
width on the image itself so that it can
be responsive inside its figure parent
and then we take a look at this in all
three different languages that we looked
at before we're like great that is
exact same CSS for every language and it
doesn't break no matter which language
were using it's awesome that's awesome
good cool there are also ways to use
different CSS for different languages
and we can you've probably seen before
how to specify the exactly perfect
typographic quotes for an element using
the quotes declaration inside q we can
just stick any Unicode this is the
Unicode for fancy-pants opening quote
Unicode for a fancy-pants closing
opening quote any Unicode in there will
work and that's great for default if the
majority of folks who visit your site
are using are going to be reading it in
english but in germany i'm told that we
use different quote marks those funny
little guys down at the bottom no
problem on the HTML we can set a
language attribute equal to d e and now
in normally you probably want to put the
language attribute on your body element
but in this case just for demos you can
stuff it on any old element you want
then this is paired with the language
pseudo class in the CSS and different
unicode characters for the quote marks
awesome great same thing for japanese we
want to have different quote marks so we
just match the Jaypee language attribute
for the quote element with a JP pseudo
class for the quote elements and you can
just paste the marks in there directly
if you don't want to track down their
unicode codes that works too i mentioned
before that this will work with any set
of unicode or any characters so what
I've done here is I've stolen the
language code for Esperanto to make an
emoji version of the quote that I was
using before the the values that are
legal inside these attributes come from
the iso 639 language codes which you can
google for there's really a lot and I
just stole Esperanto s which is e 0 NE 0
and so I've decided that for
oh gee we're going to open our quotes
with donut we're going to close it with
coffee and that's what we see over here
donut and coffee so y'all have probably
seen text transform before and perhaps
you know that in the past there were
some problems with the implementations
of text transform in browsers the most
recent updates to the CSS to text
transform law module lay out some
additional rules which correct problems
from previous modules and that's pretty
awesome for example one of the problems
previously was that if using text
transform capitalize which is supposed
to capitalize every word in a character
that works pretty good but right in here
this idea graph for Dutch both
characters are supposed to be
capitalized because they're kind of
considered a d1 character and that's
fixed in the most current version of the
css3 module and most browsers support it
chrome does super the most recent
version of Firefox also supports another
fix one of the problems was that in
German the SS character when it's
capitalized is supposed to be 2 s's not
the shoes that you've probably seen
before well firefox fixes that swell
great super but I Microsoft edge doesn't
quite do that we've still got shoes
hanging out there when it should be to
us as instead sadface so some of the
updates are available in a lot of
browsers but not all of them are and in
fact I would encourage you to be really
really cautious with any use of text
transform period because for me it's
trey is really really close to the idea
of using CSS which is for styling to
change the content of a language for
example you probably saw the Wi-Fi
password was in all caps because it
looked lovely on the slideshow but when
you type the Wi-Fi password and it's
supposed to be lowercase
so probably just let the content owners
the text writers write what they mean
instead of forcing style changes upon
them in the CSS probably stay away from
that but if you're thinking about using
text transform if you must check the
specs because it sort of kind of works
better than it used to and that's what
we can expect now let's take a look at
headlines which are a fairly common
element that you'll see in a lot of
designs in fact this is a fairly common
design that I get from my designer where
they want the headline to be scooched in
a little bit from the containing box for
emphasis because the headline is
obviously looking much more interesting
if it's scooched in from the rest of the
text and it's got a centered
call-to-action button cool pretty
standard this should not be hard at all
you would not believe how many slides i
actually have on this head ok well the
market is pretty simple we're just going
to start with a section that will give
us a place to throw our gradient on and
the section is going to contain a
headline we're going to put a line break
in the headline and we're going to have
an anchor to be our call to action
button so that's pretty cool yeah we're
going to affect that big fat Martin
margin just by stuffing it on the
section element so we've given a side
padding of uh we've given a top padding
of three rounds and a slide padding of
five rounds to scoop to everything in oh
okay should be great great yeah perfect
time for that donut after all right no
no as soon as we change the window to be
a little bit skinnier than before it
starts to look a little odd and in
reality if you have a responsive site
your Tennessee skinny or Windows all the
time also oh that German it begins to
look weird again okay well we'll do
better will iterate on this headline a
little so instead of just adding a big
giant margin just Guiche everything in
let's let's tone that down a little bit
or sorry padding we're going to change
the padding a little bit and make it
just three rounds in two rounds and then
we're going to give the headline the
more specific styling we're going to
make the headline element eighty five
percent of the width and we're going to
give it large and left auto and margin
right auto which is how we've been
centering elements for years okay okay
great that looks pretty good here we are
highlighting the element than just
showing the padding on the outside that
looks much better we still have the
squeeze effect on the headline super in
fact if we think ahead to what the
content owners might do someone might
come along and add a paragraph to this
element without even telling the poor
developers first and it's still going to
look good because we've scooched in the
headline itself instead of kin trusting
that the container is going to take care
of the big fat padding for us god it
still looks a little awkward in German
though I wish I wish there was something
more to do about fallen hoon hanging out
down at the bottom there ok tangent time
let's talk about widows and orphans has
anybody heard of the term widows and
orphans before excellent excellent it's
the single lines that are cut off from
the bottom of their blocks this line of
text down here at the bottom that's a
widow and this other line of text all
alone way up at the top that's an orphan
you all know that this came from the
days of print and typesetting when you
would move your little blocks around
then squish ink on it and in CSS widow
and orphan declarations are supported
when using page media when you're using
print media type you can specify how
many lines you want left alone at the
end of the page or the top of a new page
and that's awesome that's cool you can
also do it in columns sort of kind of in
some browsers these declarations in the
CSS should mean that the browser will
attempt to rebalance all of the text in
the columns so that three is the fewest
number of lines left alone either at the
top or the bottom of any single column
and in browses where it works
it works great currently it works in
edge 20 that's the current version of
edge and iOS Safari eight awesome does
not work in the most recent version of
Firefox or Chrome or OSX Safari okay
that's fine that's fine a progressive
enhancement it's fine you can just use
it and it'll be fine but wouldn't it be
great if we could use orphans for
something else let go imagine for me
this is not real this doesn't actually
work but imagine that you have a bunch
of elements like this more kittens which
you laid out with flex box and at the
end you've got this one little kitten
hanging out all alone it's sad and
lonely and it's much too long and it
looks weird what if you could specify an
orphans declaration on the containing
elements then the browser would stick
these two kittens together because we've
specified minimum number of children to
be rendered after a soft line break is
too that would be awesome that would be
much better are you hearing me browser
vendors orphans for other things pretty
please thank you okay yeah okay
yeah yeah this thing so we can also use
it to fix our headline for example we
could declare it would be great if we
could say that the minimum number of
words things separated by spaces left
alone at the bottom of the h1 would be
four and then the browser would just
steal some words above and make it
balance just like it does for Collins
that would be wonderful if we could do
it for our headline okay oh great so we
can't yet but maybe someday to be great
okay there's one I told you there were a
lot of slides about headline but we're
almost done there's one more reasonably
labor-intensive thing that you can do if
you absolutely must to take care of line
breaks to handle ugly-looking headlines
in this image what we have is a yellow
line that I drew in there to represent
the line break remember in the beginning
I put a hard line break in the mark-up
we can compare we can use this with
media queries and we can hide the line
breaks in certain scenarios here for
view ports that are less than 500 pixels
wide we're going to display the line
break is normal that's fine swell cool
but for wider view ports the line breaks
still exists we're just not going to
show it so if you really must force line
breaks into your code or allow your
content owners to force line breaks into
the content that they're writing you can
absolutely show and hide them using
media queries so yeah that's pretty cool
it's probably the best way right now to
handle the ugly headline but it's pretty
labor-intensive so it's your call the
last saw mo I'm going to go back to
talking about the group of boxes because
we have some pretty good fixes for that
what we want what the comp says is that
we're going to have three boxes all side
by side they're all going to be the same
height and they're going to be nicely
aligned the paragraphs are going to
start at the same place and the
call-to-action buttons are going to
start at the same place
now back in the day you might have done
this with tables because when you use
tables you get all that alignment
between rows for free and that's awesome
but this is not tabular data so we're
not going to use tables it's also going
to look pretty terrible when we need a
single column view for a mobile kind of
browser with let's let's take a look at
how we might accomplish this the mark-up
is you know not too exciting we're going
to use a section to contain all three of
the boxes and then inside there we're
going to have a div with a class of
group contain each of the columns in
there and each of those contains a
headline and a paragraph and a button
pretty standard pretty awesome the
styling we're going to start out pretty
simple at least these days we get curved
corners almost for free so that's
awesome so we're going to curve the
corners with good old border radius
we're going to send you some things add
some background colors cool simple stuff
we're going to do a lot of work on the
button but it's not too exciting really
the most exciting thing on the button is
that we're going to give it a width of
sixty percent and we're going to send to
write using margin again and let's talk
for a minute about why we can send your
things using margin auto on the left and
margin auto on the right that's kind of
weird why does it work well what happens
is that the auto Declaration takes all
of the available space on the side that
it's talking about and then it uses that
and it's okay that's my space now and
then it divides that between everything
that's going to use some of that space
so auto on the left takes half the
available space auto on the right takes
half the available space and thus the
element which is no longer a hundred
percent of the width is centered inside
its container so that's that's my maybe
interesting about auto we'll see okay
cool let's take care of the boxes for
each of the groups to keep them all the
same height and side by side we're going
to use our friend flexbox now again
flexbox still need some prefixing
another brow
so check out can I use or the Mozilla
developer network to see what you need
to add to get it to work in your
browser's flexbox is great because it
gives us this auto alignment the it's
set to stretch by default everything's
the same height all of that comes pretty
much for free the only thing I had to
add was display flex on the parent
section so that's awesome and we're also
going to set display flex inside each of
these container boxes we don't want to
use the default direction of rows
instead we want the Flex direction
inside these to be columns so that's
cool I don't know it didn't really make
a big difference inside but what it does
do it sets us up to move all of the
buttons to the bottom and the reason
that all the buttons are at the bottom
is that I've set the margin top to the
auto before I mentioned that auto takes
up all of this vailable space and
flexbox it does that on the top two so
now all of these buttons just have huge
margins when they can from the top of
their available space so margin auto
within flexbox scooches everything down
to the bottom all of our buttons are
aligned that's awesome the only thing we
need to do is to get those paragraphs of
copy aligned ah how do we do that
they're all within different parents
they don't inherently have any
relationship to them to each other so
we're going to have to cheat it's going
to be okay what we're going to do is
we're going to steal some of the margin
for our H ones we're going to set that
to margin zero steal that margin and
instead we're going to tell them that
each of these elements has a minimum
height of 10 our EMS of 10 rounds so
instead this white space is just made up
by this element having a height now in
cases where the headline contents are
actually taller than 10 REMS what's
going to happen
is it's going to push the paragraphs
down and every box is going to have the
same bottom line to it the boxes are
still going to be aligned but the
paragraphs won't be because one
paragraph will be pushed down much
further by its headline than the other
ones and I think that's okay because the
alternate option if we were to use just
height instead of men height would mean
that for very long hy elements we would
be cut off at the bottom when the
content don't fit inside the elements so
I think it's better to suffer some
layout to some layout breakage than to
kill content for the users wow so that
was a lot of CSS that I just threw at
you all let's let's take a look at what
we did already today we looked at how to
position a caption at the bottom of its
parent using position relative to
capture the containing context and also
how to size it based on its parent using
Mac's content which is very awesome we
looked at how to use the language a
tribute and the same language
pseudo-class to do any kind of quote
marks that you want and this will allow
you to any styling that you want
different for different languages if
it's necessary for your site you can
increase the type chinese text size but
only for chinese we talked about how to
use text transform how it's changed with
the recent CSS module updates and how
maybe you want to be really really
deliberate and thoughtful before just
throwing it on your headlines we talked
about a wish for using orphans and widow
declarations in things other than paged
media or columns that would be pretty
swell we talked a lot about how you can
corral headlines down to pin this the
page size I think that the best standard
solution is just to give it a different
with and center it but you can also show
and hide the line breaks if you really
want to and we also talked about how can
use flex box to magically auto align a
bunch of things inside there
most interestingly i think is the way
the top margin auto works so of course
you can combine any of these techniques
as you need to I think the important
thing to think about is to plan for the
text size that you put out there to vary
because content owners are going to
change it users who up their font size
are going to change it and even if you
include any content that's dynamic from
a database or from the users or from
translations that's going to change the
size of boxes that you need on your
website so just go ahead and plan for it
building a robust site that survived the
localization process is going to be
building a site which handles all of
these so that's what I came to talk
about again if you want you can get the
links from KDK to github do /
localizations or you can follow me on
twitter or read them up my blog which I
swear really is pew pew lasercom I've
had that for years I did not make this
up and so there we go that's it thank
you